you got a pretty supportive gay and
lesbian community in this city I did
want to ask you about something you
wrote A couple of years ago you said if
I had a gay son I would think i' oh look
another another I'm saying a swamp you
guys a swamp over the weekend there was
a press conference for this fight and
UFC middleweight champ his name is Shan
Strickland uh he got into it with a
reporter a woke reporter of course uh
trying to get him on some past comments
and I want you to watch how it doesn't
even matter if you completely agree with
him or not or agree with their reporter
or not I want you to watch how he fights
back on the woke reporter and then think
does that remind you of a certain orange
man who's suddenly
surging uh we've got a pretty supportive
gay and lesbian community in this city I
did want to ask you about something you
wrote a couple years ago you said if I
had a gay son I would think i' oh look
another another I'm saying a swamp you
guys a swamp you've become a champion
you become a star and and someone let me
ask you something are you are you are
you gay had the chance to with a more
diverse are you let me know are you gay
can I can I get answer well I'm asking
this is the part are you are you a gay
man I'm an ally of the community okay if
you had a son then he was like you know
he had a son he was gay you'd be like oh
man you don't you don't want a grandkid
no problem with it oh man well dude
you're a weak man dude you're like
you're part of the problem you elected
Justin Chau like what you when he sees
the bank accounts like you're just
pathetic and and the fact that the fact
that you have no backbone and and has he
shut down your country and seiz bank
accounts you asked me some stupid like
that go yourself move the on man
question he's well spoken I'll give him
that much um okay it doesn't even matter
if you agree with all of the specifics
and I could get into some of the Nuance
there um it that's not really the point
the broader point is that this guy uh is
going after the media in a very trumpan
way and that led to me when he's talking
about what Trudeau did with the truckers
and everything else you were he's
basically saying people like you that
led to this effed up situation in this
country and then thousands of people
start chanting F Trudeau it's like
there's a connection there there's a
connection between how those things are
happening and there's also a connection
that finally a whole bunch of us and it
doesn't mean that I agree with
everything that this Strickland guy says
or I agree with everything that Trump
says but enough of us are just like
enough F you people not just F Trudeau F
all of you people who have guilted us
and gone after us and tried to shut down
our bank accounts and everything else so
the problem of course with the woke is
that they are so so fixated on these
faux social issues uh that they actually
ignore real T tyranny when it comes from
the real tyrants but I want to show you
we'll get into that in just a sec I want
to show you a bit more uh from that
press conference with Strickland because
he's also not having it uh with Bud
Light and uh and the trans thing but I
did want to ask also things you said
about the trans Community you said uh
this past October when they announced
the budlight sponsorship that you'd go
so hard on budlight in your next fight
they'll have to accept me or denounce me
when uh when and they know what and will
know what they stand for are you this
guy's like this Canadian is not that
Canadian are you still going to use your
fight time to kind of speak on that
here's the thing about Bud
Light here's the thing about Bud
Light 10 years ago to be trans was a
what a mental illness and now all of a
sudden people like you have weasel your
way in the
world you are you are an
infection you are the definition of
weakness everything that is is wrong
with the world is because of you and the
best thing is is the world's not buying
it the world's not buying your bull
you're pedling the world is not saying
you know what you're right chicks have
world's not saying that world's saying
no there are two genders I don't want my
kids being taught about you know who
they could in school I don't want my
kids being taught about you know their
sexual preference like dude this guy is
a enemy you want to look at the enemy to
our world world it's that mother right
there asking these stupid questions okay
again you don't have to agree with
exactly how he's saying it or anything
else um but he he is like directionally
right and also again it illustrates the
broader point of enough people have had
enough of this and you know when I talk
about how I don't watch the NBA anymore
because everything's been so politicized
it's like do you think that that this
guy when he was training to be a great
Fighter for years and years and years
thought that oh mostly when he would be
giving press conferences before the
biggest fight of his life he'd be
talking about whether girls or boys and
boys are girls and everything else so it
has wokeism has infected literally
everything in society from the military
down to the UFC and everything in
between and now people have had
enough